welcome to this video playing DD one of
the very frequent opponents let's see ya
think he is playing the Slav and try and
for queen bee three again about 12 and 0
this is this is a rare rare answer maybe
just just here but if I got 12 wins
against him for losses one draw not very
not very draw this score always fight it
seems yeah in this type of position 20x
b3 is nothing that worries me too much
the open a file is very nice yeah night
to be formed should I play c5 here
always tough tough too tough to assess
maybe just just develop a night before I
look see one should be ok or is them
move like King d2 is this sir is this
does this make any sense Nigeria g2 is
ok yeah maybe maybe just do it I've got
III use useful developing moves and
maybe I can Bishop c2 there is night 82
I guess
yeah I want okay three for that matter
this is really doesn't really help him
okay i wonder if i can i can should
probably flick this in any way I wonder
about see 598 form this would be nice to
play but c5 rook a for not 94 but yeah I
need to I need to have the other look
available ok let's do it rook a4 a5 rook
f 2 a1 and a5 is a problem for him
yeah that looks okay I think unless them
unless there is something something
tactical happening yeah I'm still not
totally sold on the roof and on the
kingda to idea but it worked out okay I
guess check yeah okay at least here I am
probably don't need to think a lot I can
just take it I interesting with the pawn
but I have 95 and 94 this idea okay I'm
not going to retreat anyway so let's
just move the night okay well this was
the idea gaining this this good square
but okay I don't mind this position very
much the only thing that might turn out
to be a problem is my my king of course
22 what what is a good plan maybe night
see for Bishop d6 getting getting this
Bishop traded and making sure that
there's a night on d6 that's one idea
the other idea that could be interesting
as Knight to f5 but I need to be need to
be careful here with my kingdom being on
d 2 and very tricky position also the
ship c5 takes and a night discovery but
I don't really see where yeah don't
don't see where this this could could
hit me
interesting I do and also I don't have
any any good place for the King rear for
their father for the King to go he does
not really have any discovery right I
want to go king he won Bishop c5 DC
night somewhere but I don't see why I
can hurt me really drop back if he five
I think I can really just take it's not
a big problem um okay yeah now night a
fire becomes somewhat more attractive
but ok does this seems to be good anyway
let's let's get this done no night to d6
so possibly threatening night f5 at the
right moment the right moment it's not
really great in many in many kok just it
just gives gives this away can yes this
of course possible and to get rid of the
night as soon as possible here ok so my
idea must be now to to open up the Kings
side the only place where i can actually
open up the position look H 1 group g1
and so on Queen side is is pretty much
okay as it is yeah g4 is the idea here
we go whether this is just this is just
very good for what he does not really
have enough compensation for for the
material
and I can push the edge porn but further
they even now let's see how the King on
b5 could be problematic but okay if I
take it high morning I can still I can
just go all the way to f4 yeah yeah okay
I must I must do that pro problem and
accept that his King s is doing this
okay Chad here can take b7 now I can
just pick up the points I don't need to
rush things
is there a very clear winner come on
leather that's enough no reason just you
just hit the wrong button it happens to
me a lot poo yeah a tough game tough
game I mean around here maybe in the
King position is some compensation for
his structural problems but I'm not
really sure about all of that very very
tricky position this looks okay rook the
am now maybe I can play B should be six
immediately i wasn't sure i was really
unsure about the King on the two as
always feels a bit strange opposing the
rook so I went I went for this first
yeah a six is a move that is really
strategically undesirable but maybe how
that you cannot do without it if we can
small dark squares yeah out here well I
just went for this okay it's clear that
rock d success is an option Joe maybe I
would have done that myself I mean the
track night only six is really tough to
to accept yeah I think this is this is
just the way to go I need to get rid of
the night and now make sure that this is
coordinated I'm not sure that you can
really avoid the opening here on the
honor of the king side in the long run
you can play with h4 but there's still
g3 happening something like that
okay maybe yeah this is in fact an idea
maybe he can play like that now this is
possible intending to do to block it
with the rook back I still don't believe
it long term maybe maybe you can hold it
this black maybe something like this and
then we'll get one f3 i still have ways
to open the position mmm okay well maybe
you can put it on e6 and look away yeah
this is very fortress-like something
like this yeah we gave eight bishop only
for others there is a little chance to
to to make progress down yeah probably
with with precise play white white black
and black and her with it should i do I
have something else maybe I should play
a three here tough to have the same
tough the same some prolly this should
be should be enough for black but or
maybe I need to combine it with
something else will be five at some
point yeah well what i'm talkin about
let's say i play and this is already too
late actually maybe object maybe i
should think about something like that
just giving up a pawn to to get an
additional open file something like this
yeah but what exactly is it doing maybe
Luke a three-year okay one look ahead
and look at this nobody's God's can
simply play bishops yet yeah it's very
George probably okay thanks for watching